joining me now is Madeline Bram she's
the National Crime Victims Advocate and
CEO of rescue Angel and Horace Cooper
author and legal commentator Madeline
um I want to get your reaction to what I
just said because
you aren't
um a political pundit or commentator
you're someone who voted Democrat for
most of your life tell us what you're
seeing out there
thank you Laura so much for having me
that was a powerful
segment that you just presented and you
summed it up
basically you know uh what
the African-American Community is
experiencing
myself as a 40-year loyal Democrat
because that's what we were told that
black people were supposed to vote was
Democrat
until I realized
in 2020 after my son was killed the way
I was treated by the criminal justice
system here in New York and the the
justice that I did not receive for the
murder of my son by Democratic district
attorney Alvin Bragg
and then I like everyone else all you
have to do is just step out of your
front door and you could see the
dilapidated housing the failing schools
the crime the poverty The Runaway drug
use the abortion the open-air uh you
know uh safe injection sites all of that
stuff you don't have to go far when
you're from the hood all you have to do
is step outside your door but we
continue to give our votes away for
nothing in return so that's one of the
primary reasons why I decided to vote
for Trump in 2020 then I officially
changed my party affiliation to
conservative because I have
conservative values I believe in God
nuclear family and Country
unapologetically I was raised with those
values but because I'm black I was told
that that's what Democrats are supposed
to vote and Madeline what's your message
now before we get to Horace what's your
message now
to Joe Biden because his point is white
supremacy is the biggest threat to the
country or Black America now is that the
way you see it absolutely not the
biggest threat to America right now is
that they continue
to impose on us and we continue to chase
the ghosts of slavery past and we
continue to continue with the narrative
to keep us enslaved in our minds with
the slavery and oppression and racism
we've been marching for 60 damn years to
reach the Mountaintop
and we have not made it yet we have the
AL sharpens al-shopters of the world who
now is going to go in March
while the rest of us are at the bottom
of the hill for 60 years he seems to be
the only one has made it to the
Mountaintop
Horace um
this is a powerful message from Madeline
and I think there are a lot of people
across the country who didn't experience
the just a horrific tragedy that she did
and received the treatment from Bragg
that she believes she she received but
do you see this as a perhaps a turning
point among some segment of the black
community given what's happened to this
nation in two and a half years
well first let me say this project 21 is
non-partisan we are made up of
conservatives and Libertarians a lot of
of Americans who share our views like
family like hard work and patriotism I
just had my most recent book out how
Biden's policies harm blacks it's put
you all back in Chains
more and more black Americans are
looking around and they are seeing that
these policies the Dynamics of vision
hurts America and it particularly hurts
blacks the main reason for that is
the best advice anyone could give you
don't partner with a deadbeat dad the
Democrats the the progressives have
pushed a deadbeat dad it's called Uncle
Sam big government whatever you want to
call it the check
this deadbeat dad does not care about
your child in fact this deadbeat dad
will push you to abort your child this
deadbeat dad is going to see
in the most corrupt and dangerous
Community possible this deadbeat dad
doesn't put your interest first it puts
the green agenda first
the lgbtq agenda first black Americans
have found under Biden that their issues
are going to the back of the political
bus and more and more black Americans
realize the deadbeat dad is not the
answer for them
Madeline Joe Biden spoke about the
economy today and again they're selling
this as the great Reawakening of growth
and prosperity this is what he said
binomics is just another way of saying
restoring the American dream I'm proud
of the historic laws my Administration
has passed
through the right steps not only get our
iconic movement again and but to build a
future better than the past
I'm not trying to return to the Past I'm
trying to be better for future than we
had
Madeline is that what African Americans
are saying that the the the future is
looking really bright with cost of
energy and the cost of living and the
rising crime and the open border that's
that's all going to be good for Black
America absolutely not three years ago
the same salary okay
used to pay all of my bills all right I
would able to was able to live from
paycheck to paycheck maybe save a few
dollars all right
um get my credit
you know pay off my credit cards three
years later
I'm now scraping the bottom of my change
jar all right to buy a loaf of bread all
right with the same salary the same
spending habits and everything all right
Joe Biden is lying about the economy all
right we are being killed out here the
middle class has been pushed down until
the Working Poor the Working Poor has
been pushed down to the working dirt
poor all right we cannot survive all
right we are barely making it with the
same salary with the same spending
habits the prices are just out of
control out of control I hope the
country tonight is watching I hope
Republicans who want to run for office I
hope they're watching this and I hope we
as Americans can come together for a
better day because this really this is
about common sense at some point
Madeline and Horace thank you both hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis says you will not
get it anywhere else